E
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND I LOVE THAT
YOU UNDERSTAND THIS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR JOINING
ME TONIGHT, I WANT TO TALK NOW
WITH JONATHAN TURLEY WHO WAS
KIND ENOUGH TO JOIN US WHO
CERTAINLY HAS HIS PERSPECTIVE AS
A LAW PROFESSOR DEALING WITH A
LOT OF THESE ISSUES TO SAY THE
LEAST, THANK YOU CONGRESSMAN
COMBER.
PER USUAL THE FBI -- HE'S SAYING
THE FBI HAS TO BE DISMANTLED,
THE FBI HAS ADMITTED NO
WRONGDOING LET ME START WITH
THIS.
THEY HAVE ADMITTED NO
WRONGDOING -- WHY WOULD THEY?
WRITING IN A STATEMENT THE
BUREAU REGULARLY ENGAGES WITH
PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES THAT
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT IF ANY
ACTION THEY TAKE ON THEIR
PLATFORMS AND FOR THEIR
CUSTOMERS AFTER THE FBI HAS
NOTIFIED THEM.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JONATHAN
TURLEY, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THAT KIND OF STATEMENT WITH WHAT
WE KNOW NOW FROM THIS RECENT
DROP OF THE TWITTER FILES?
>> WAS DISTURBING ABOUT THIS
STATEMENT IS IT SHOWS ABSOLUTELY
NO SELF-AWARENESS OF WHAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN DISCLOSED.
IT'S SHOWING UTTER CONTEMPT OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE FBI COULD HAVE SAID WE FIND
THESE ALLEGATIONS DISTURBING, WE
ARE GOING TO CONDUCT OUR OWN
IMMEDIATE INVESTIGATION TO SEE
IF THESE TYPES OF CONTACTS WENT
TOO FAR AND INSTEAD THEY SAY WE
DID NOTHING BUT CORRESPOND WITH
COMPANIES, THAT IS NOT WHAT
THESE NEW FILES ARE SUGGESTING,
THEY ARE SUGGESTING CENSORSHIP
BY SURROGATES, BY PROXY.
YOU HAVE DOZENS OF FBI AGENTS
WHO SUPPOSEDLY WERE TASKED TO GO
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA, YOU HAVE
150 CONTACTS WITH JUST ONE
TWITTER EXECUTIVE GIVING LISTS
OF USERS THAT SHOULD BE BANNED,
INCLUDING SATIRICAL SITES,
THERE'S VERY LITTLE RUNWAY LEFT
FOR THE FBI TO CONTINUE TO DENY
THAT THERE ISN'T A SERIOUS
PROBLEM HERE.
PEOPLE I THINK LARGELY AGREE, I
HOPE THAT WHILE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT APPLIES TO THE
GOVERNMENT, IT ALSO APPLIES TO
AGENTS OF THE GOVERNMENT -- IF
THE FBI USES A PROXY, USES AN
AGENT LIKE TWITTER, IT'S STILL
CENSORSHIP, IT'S STILL A
VIOLATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
>> Tammy: WHAT IS INTERESTING
HERE TOO AND I THINK AMERICANS
ARE FRUSTRATED BECAUSE WITH THE
FBI, WHETHER IT'S THE RUSSIA
DOSSIER HOPES, THE INTERFERENCE
SOME ARGUE IN THE 2016 AND 2020
ELECTIONS IS THAT NOTHING EVER
SEEMS TO HAPPEN.
ARE WE MISSING SOMETHING THAT
CONGRESS CAN DO OTHER THAN HAVE
REALITY TELEVISION COMMITTEES
EVERY DAY?
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
DONE IMMEDIATELY ESPECIALLY WITH
YOUR REMARKS ABOUT THEIR
STATEMENT WHICH EFFECTIVELY
CONFIRMS THAT THEY SEEM TO BE
FINE, THEY KNEW ABOUT IT, THEY
WEREN'T OUTRAGED OR SHOCKED --
WHAT ARE THE OPTIONS HERE?
>> OBVIOUSLY IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME TO BUILD THE TYPE OF
CASE FOR SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE, I
DON'T THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT DISMANTLING THE
FBI, WHAT THE REPRESENTATIVE IS
TALKING ABOUT IS DISMANTLING
THESE TROUBLESOME COMPONENTS OF
THE FBI, IF THERE IS A
CENSORSHIP PROGRAM GOING ON AND
WE DO NEED TO LOOK AT THAT BUT A
CASE HAS TO BE MADE.
THESE FILES ARE NOT JUST AN
INDICTMENT OF THE FBI, THEY ARE
AN INDICTMENT OF CONGRESS.
CONGRESS HAS SHOWN A STEADFAST
REFUSAL TO DIG INTO THE
CENSORSHIP ALLEGATIONS, MANY OF
US HAVE BEEN WRITING ABOUT THIS
FOR YEARS.
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS HAVE
REFUSED TO PURSUE THIS AND IN
FACT DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS HAVE
PUSHED SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO
EXPAND CENSORSHIP.
IN THE VERY HEARING WHERE
JACK DORSEY APOLOGIZED FOR THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP DEBACLE, THE
IMMEDIATE REACTION OF DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS WERE TO SAY DON'T
BACKSLIDE ON US, WE WANT MORE
CENSORSHIP.
NOW WE HAVE NOT JUST CENSORSHIP,
WE HAVE BLACKLISTING, WE HAVE
THESE SHADOW BANDS, ALL OF THAT
IS OPEN TO THE PUBLIC.
IN SOME WAYS HE HAS FORCED
PEOPLE TO CHOOSE SIDES.
I THINK SOME OF THE ANGER USING
THE MEDIA BORDERS ON
SELF-LOATHING, THEY ARE HAPPY TO
EMBRACE NOT JUST CENSORSHIP
APOLOGIST BUT BLACKLISTING AND
SHADOW BANNING AND ALSO LYING
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS --
THAT'S A LOT TO TAKE ON YOURSELF
AND STILL CLAIM THAT YOU ARE A
JOURNALIST OR YOU BELIEVE IN
FREE SPEECH.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A WHILE BUT I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW LONG OVERDUE
THIS IS, WE NEED TO SEE IT ALL
AND HOPEFULLY THE HOUSE IS GOING
TO PURSUE THAT.
>> Tammy: GREAT STUFF AND YOU
HAVE BEEN ONE OF THEM, THIS HAS
BEEN ON YOUR PLATE FOR YEARS AND
AN EXCELLENT POINT ABOUT
CONGRESS AND THEIR ABDICATED
RESPONSIBILITY OR THEIR
COMPLICIT NESTS -- FOR THOSE OF
US WHO ARE CLASSICAL LIBERALS,
WE USED TO BE AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT SPY